hey guys Justin here with a GameSpot
news update it looks like amazon has
purchased game streaming company twitch
TV for close to 1 billion dollars this
news comes as a surprise as only
recently there were rumors of Google
owns YouTube buying the company the CEO
of twitch Emmett shear wrote in a
statement we chose Amazon because they
believe in our community they share our
values and long-term vision and they
want to help us get there faster we're
keeping most everything the same our
office our employees our brand and most
importantly our independence but when
Amazon's support will have the resources
to bring you an even better twitch
according to a report released this
spring twitch is the largest live
streaming website in the United States
by a large margin Amazon has recently
been making moves into the video game
market attracting talent like the
designers a portal and far cry and
purchasing killer instinct and developer
double helix games no word yet on any
changes for twitch users but we'll keep
you updated on gamespot calm